[Musique]
les âmes ouais alors dites-nous toit
pour moi l'émission elle a quitté son
principe de base c'est quoi le principe
de base c'est à dire qu'au départ
c'était une émission bon divertissent et
un peu mais il y avait beaucoup d'infos
on savait ce qui se passait il ya
beaucoup d'infos alors que là maintenant
pour moi y'a plus de divertissement que
d'un faux et l'émission elle dure
tellement longtemps
tous les jours que ça lasse c'est à dire
que moi à 2 heures du matin j'ai du mal
à dormir il ya des pmp sur s'est vite
taillé fowler midi j'ai faim j'ai pas
entre midi et deux il ya ces 8 je me
lève le matin et dans les heures non il
ya cette nouvelle édition entre midi et
deux avec marc bürki qu'on embrasse qui
m'envoyait un très gentil et c'est
maintenant les pas derrière l'émotion ça
c'est à tomber quoi il a été derrière
elle dort je crois que cela
non merci non mais voilà non mais bon
mais je franchement pour vous répondre
je vous dis à beaucoup d'infos dans tpm
paix et forcément on est obligé de faire
beaucoup de divertissements mais c'est
vrai que les gens en fait quand il je
pense que quand il revoit quelques
séquences les séquences qui sont le plus
reprise sont des séquences à de
divertissement de tirer que cette
semaine par exemple j'ai vu surtout les
transferts télé ils sont tous repris de
tpm paix les infos de thierry ou des
infos de maxime vieni la rédaction ou de
la rédaction ou de julien courbet qui
nous dit qu'il va rester sur ces huit
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez une
réponse aaa donnée
benjamin que juste pour vous répondre
mais ce qui m'a le plus fait pas un peu
plus forme c'est ce qui m'a étonné le
plus dans l'émission c'est que cyril en
permanence il réajuste le contenu des
émissions parfois fait des semaines on a
fait plus de divertissement et contrôler
ce que vous pensez il se rend compte que
parfois les missions est trop drôle
divertissement et s'est lui-même heroes
motive ses troupes qui refait les
comptes et des heures où je trouve cette
info keane ou qu'ils nous convoquent qui
nous engueule parfois pas moi pas
spécialement mais vous beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que c'est ce qui m'a le plus
bluffé c'est que l'on pourrait penser
que cyril fait beaucoup le mariole et
qui fait que du show et je peux vous
dire c'est ce qui m'a le plus vraiment
interpellé c'est que ces rides il est
tous les matins vers 10h 11h
d'ailleurs en conférence de rédaction y
voit le conducteur il leur fait et quand
il sent qu'il a été dans une mauvaise
direction c'est le premier à dire j'ai
fait de la merde et ça croyez moi pour
les vidéos je vous raconte une anecdote
qui est vrai c'est vrai que je vous le
dis entre septembre et décembre
c'est prévu cette année j'étais très
très mécontent de l'émission bred la
tournure que prenaient les missions et
j'étais très mécontent d y en décembre
j'ai pas du tout pris de vacances je
vous le dis et j'ai voulu dit j'ai
refait tout le conducteur et j'ai voulu
tout changer dans l'émission j'ai appelé
tous les chroniqueurs
j'ai appelé tous les gens de la prod
j'ai dit on va tout changer parce que
j'aime pas du tout la direction qu'elle
prend et je trouvais donc je suis
d'accord avec certains d'entre vous sur
septembre décembre depuis janvier
d'ailleurs on le voit est l'émission n'a
jamais aussi bien marché sur toutes les
cibles c'est qu'on a vraiment recentrer
sur les infos avec on est obligé de
faire du divertissement parce que c'est
notre franchement où nous allons faire
en plus de faire ce que je ne se marier
c'est pas là mais je sais mais c'est
vrai que je suis d'accord et vous
jusqu'à décembre
c'est vrai que septembre décembre je
peux le dire moi aujourd'hui au ce soir
on a fait une rentrée qui est un petit
peu bancal voilà et c'est vrai que
depuis janvier je suis extrêmement
content démission je crois que les
téléspectateurs aussi et on va aller de
plus en plus dense que vous aimez et on
écoute beaucoup les gens que ce soit sur
twitter sur facebook partout sur les
réseaux sociaux voilà et c'est vrai
qu'on vous écoute à chaque fois on
essaie d'adapter les missions à ce que
vous aimez en tout cas je voudrais
remercier voudrais vous remercier
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]